I'm in front of the cabin what I'm about
to say is not made up praying once Allah
right here is the equivalent to a
hundred thousand imagine you watch this
video and donate 100 pounds for 10
salamats and from 10 of them only one
just comes to the Kaaba we aren't saying
we bring people to omra but we teach
brothers and sisters like Khalid how to
praise Allah and praise all their Salah
for four days praise the janaza praise
the jummah praise all their five salons
the donor gets the reward so do not miss
on this reward click the button or the
link and donate now
so basically I'm about to release the
marriage documentary episode one it's
been nearly seven years as you can see
on my screen on the left or the right
that's the documentary
I'm gonna go to edit video
I'm gonna go to public bismil library
because the historical moment I'm so
excited literally 7 36 the 13th of April
2023 may Allah make it a means
this project is more than entertainment
this is tawheed yes
this is tawheed in essence of having
tawakul and having trust in Allah from
the moment I accepted Islam and for
everybody inshallah to seeking marriage
in a Halal way you're going to see in
Charlotte in a different aspects upon
Allah it's about to call public right
you ready ready you want to press it
okay there you go guys
I'm so excited I'm gonna do stage the
sugar
which is when the person would hear good
news he will do this and you can do it
any Direction that's gonna be the Qibla
there we go Bismillah
wait wait wait Allah
brothers and sisters
let me double check actually
me my team memet jabby
if you knew the effort we went through
and we're gonna have some behind the
scenes stuff is
raeli benefit from it this is just the
beginning episode one as the journey
goes on wallahi some crucial stuff that
I learned that's going to benefit you
inshallah I'm not going to hold it
longer
boom it's public bro let's go
listen